[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter
theory in today's video we're going to
be discussing
the dark lord he who must not be named
lord voldemort
and what actually happened to his body
after he died
in the deathly hallows part 2 after he
was defeated
at the battle of hogwarts one thing that
i want to mention
right away is that this video is mainly
going to be focusing on the
books as in the films voldemort's body
simply disintegrates into nothing
an outcome entirely inconsistent with
the events
of the book not long before his death
voldemort and harry
shared the following exchange in the
great hall i know things you don't know
tom riddle i know lots of important
things that you don't
want to hear some before you make
another big mistake is it love again
dumbledore's favorite solution love
which he claimed to conquer
death so what will stop you dying now
when i strike
if it is not love that will save you
this time you must believe that you have
magic that i do not
or else a weapon more powerful than mine
i believe
both and after harry and voldemort's
long-awaited final skirmish
when voldemort is finally defeated by
harry his corporeal form doesn't break
off into pieces and vanish into nothing
in fact nothing special happens
voldemort is reduced to a corpse
just like anyone else voldemort always
saw death
dying as pure weakness a fate preserved
for the unimportant and powerless
i think that how his death is portrayed
in the book is quite interesting
because it was so well commonplace
they moved voldemort's body and laid it
in a chamber off the hall
away from the bodies of fred tonks lupin
colin cravey
and 50 others who died fighting him so
after being moved
what came of voldemort's corpse where
did it go
well something the films failed to
mention altogether
was the resting chamber of lord
voldemort a secret chamber
located inside of hogwarts where his
body was kept
no information was released regarding
the chamber's location
other than that it was outside of the
great hall
one important distinction to make here
however is that when voldemort died
his soul and his body his corporeal form
suffered very different fates
while voldemort's physical body may have
appeared to be at peace
and laid to rest his soul was destined
for torment
voldemort had sacrificed his soul on
countless occasions
doing anything and everything he could
to achieve his goal of immortality
during his lifetime voldemort committed
atrocity after atrocity
murdering people to create horcruxes and
even killing and drinking the blood of a
unicorn
an act so vile that the drinker is
destined to have a cursed
existence so you see voldemort's soul
could never have been
at rest and for the life that he chose
to live
he had to pay the ultimate price and
existence in limbo
for those that aren't aware limbo is a
state in which one is neither dead
or alive a place where no one can truly
be at rest
limbo is often perceived as a forgotten
or ignored place
a place that interestingly enough would
have been a stark reminder
of voldemort's formative years when he
was left at wool's orphanage as a baby
many different religions cultures view
limbo differently
however one aspect of limbo is
consistent across all of them
it's not somewhere that you want to be
some speculate that limbo
is the place that a recently deceased
person can make a choice move on to the
afterlife
or return to the world as a ghost
however jk rowling confirmed in an
interview
that because voldemort had destroyed his
soul with horcruxes
he would be permanently stuck there one
thing is for certain
voldemort paid the ultimate price for
his crimes a half-life
in eternal torment and that's it for
this video did you guys know what
happened to voldemort after his death
did you ever think about it for those
that only sold the films
i bet some of this was surprising to you
if you enjoy the content
please remember to like subscribe to
support the channel
until next time of course it's happening
inside your head harry
but why on earth should that mean that
it's not real
[Music]
you